conk nab schnoz hooter whatever you call
them not many people actually leak that
one but why did he stuck her like that
why are they made that bendy cartilage
test you're not born and why do you
always got a spot when the NDA rape
before a job I love you Earl AIDS would
be very different
F and stay the noises we just had to e
homes in the front of our face I mean
why do you think Voldemort was always so
ragin my life is terrible
like Lords of our external organs noises
evolved to help us eat and therefore
left our nose as close to mouth but
downward pointing nostrils so even at
their very last minute we can smell us
something has gone wrong noises even
helpers eat when were too young to not
to the shops ourselves by making sure we
don't suffocate while being breastfed
that little air gap created by your nose
pushing up against the breast coupled
with the fact that they're wearing sets
much higher when you're a baby means
that you can eat and breathe at the same
time the external nose is mainly made up
of a springy cartilage and it's a good
job to they take quite a bit of a
bashing through our lives so it makes a
lot of sense that the softer and less
late with this winter from shatta wale
adjusting noises are in frame possession
to take a bearing the possession is also
helpful for keeping rain water or sweat
from flowing stream until nostrils nor
all creatures are so design savvy the
Mayan mass snub-nosed monkey has an
upward pointing nose and has nicknamed
the sneezing monkey because every time
it rains
monkey goes action sounds cute but when
you're trying to live your best
camouflage like a sneeze isn't the best
way to speak consumed from credits so
your noise probably isn't as
unfortunately sheep as this snub-nosed
monkey but what if you're not happy with
Reina plastic or uncaused or to the rest
of us is the most common plastic
software it can eat over
and it's nothing new Reina plastic first
became popular during the mass syphilis
outbreak and sexy in century Europe as
one of the unfortunate symptoms of
advanced syphilis as the loss of soft
tissue and therefore your nose a nose
job then was as much fun as the disease
sergeant's would cut a flap in the arm
attached at two billion nose once was
and once it fuses with your face several
year arm free and mold what's left ant
is something resembling a nose now
pushed the thought of arm flaps from
remained and thank instead about lovely
warm environment has influenced that we
are noses evolved to and warmer climates
that has less need to warm the air up on
the we enter the lungs so the immediate
flow of air Street and to the lungs is
preferable resulting in shorter flat
long noses and colder climates you're
more lately a famed long fan noses that
are better heating and humidifying cold
air before it gets to the lines as well
as being damned yet dogs are said to
have one of the best senses of smell
going accordingly a recent study carried
out in Florida specially trained dogs
had an almost 97% accuracy and sniffing
to cancer and blood samples but our own
sense of smell certainly isn't to be
snappa humans are better than dogs
identifying the smell of some ripe
fruits simply because it's a more
valuable trait to us and if you wonder
why the smell of rape drug takes you
right back to you
2008 Benidorm weekend are featuring too
many mango daknees as because of older
memory a rather unique ability that we
possess because the part of our brain
that deals with our sense of smell is
right next to the hippocampus the area
where memories are formed
Asia
seven is from suffocation and Salmonella
sneezing and freezing as safe to say we
a whole lot of point in flat weight but
bumpy mousse
even if s where all the bogies left